now why do chefs and food lovers get so
excited about truffle season it's simple
because eating fabulous truffles is an
incredible experience and is all about
their incredible amazing aroma now
whether you're in a restaurant or
cooking at home trust me it's so hard to
beat the combination of fresh pasta and
incredible fresh truffles here's the
good news there's so much happening now
we've organized an amazing truffle hunt
across all the Gordon Ramsay restaurants
across the globe come on to the
restaurants and bars and try our
incredible truffle dishes with
incredible drinks now look I keep my
travels in a little pot of rice that way
the rice absolutely tastes of truffle
when I come to make that incredible
risotto take a picture and share on
facebook instagram or twitter using the
hashtag grg truffle hunt now in the
meantime check out our website and
social media feeds all month long our
talented chefs will be giving some great
advice using troubles at home great
recipes how to shop properly and to make
you feel more confident cooking these
little buggers yourself good luck and I
can't wait to see the pictures